[Music]  it's time for ETS late-night roundup  your quick catch-up on all the best  celebrity scoop after dark  I got hits from before you were born and  I've got hits that are my own demi  lovato and James Corden had an epic riff  off on Wednesday's Late Late Show Corden  singing hits from back then and Demi  singing hits from today girls is coming  to an end on HBO but Lena Dunham is  already planning a series reunion here's  a clip she shared on Jimmy Kimmel Live  of the girls characters way into the  future it means so much to me that you  guys are throwing in a 63rd birthday  slash divorce slash knee surgery party  near 77 years old even married eight  times anyone having knee surgery in and  around your face let's get this party  started  and over on The Tonight Show host jimmy  fallon and dwayne johnson surprised  unsuspecting fans while dressed up as  mascots but this reaction was priceless  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Music]